plenty of things on the predator
franchisor become ingrained in the
public consciousness over the decades
but there's a lot that still unknown
about these deep-space big-game hunters
and plenty of things we do know that
remain confusing we're here to help sort
it out there's a lot we don't know about
the Predators for example the word
predator it's just what Earthlings call
these monsters
we took a predator school right there
language in the movies appears to be a
collection of clicking noises
represented through a complex series of
dashes and writing so we're never quite
short they prefer to be called that said
the predator expanded universe has
revealed in the past that they're an
alien species known as de OCHA all the
hitch q-10 according to the law that
latter name is alien speak for the
people who take territory whatever you
want to call them there are a handful of
broad traits they share that come up
throughout each film first of all the
race seems to be guided by a desire to
hunt for sports often they'll seek out
whatever passes for the greatest
warriors in a given area and stalk them
as a trophy game king is hunting us
they've even been known to pass on human
beings that don't pose an immediate
threat or challenge hinting that they
might be guided by a twisted sense of
honor or sportsmanship they also seem to
typically hunt in units of no more than
three when they arrived at their hunting
grounds they're ready for combats with
elaborate armor designed to help them
track prey and turn invisible and a
helmet that allows them to see heat
signatures and other highly specific
filters on the visual spectrum if you do
manage to get through that armor you'll
be greeted with bright green luminescent
blood assuming they don't self-destruct
first not much is known about the
Predators place of origin they're
advanced enough to travel the galaxy but
they've also shown signs of having a
singular home world with its own
distinct culture and hierarchy however
none of that is really explained to any
of the human beings I did encounter the
Predators they're often too busy running
for their lives to swap stories instead
humans typically deal with the warrior
class of the Predators those that are
brave enough to pour boots on the
grounds and collect human trophies he's
on safari Lions the Tigers the Bears the
predator species has a sort of tried
mentality and they're not above having
conflicts amongst themselves in shorts
part of what makes a predator
so scary is the fact that humans don't
quite know where they come from or what
exactly they want other than to hunt
them down and dispatch them with extreme
violence the first time we see predators
in counting humanity is in 1987 in the
jungles of Central America the first
predator film sees US Special Operations
Forces veteran major Allen Doug Shaffer
lead a group of five highly trained
commandos and an old friend from the CIA
on a daring mission against some
guerrilla troops on their way to the
extraction point the group of
mercenaries finds itself stalled by
something that picks them off one by one
despite their training they are simply
no match for their bigger stronger and
more technologically advanced opponent
however the armour starts to crack when
Dutch realizes that the creature seems
to be hunting for spores when he sees it
ignore an unarmed female captive that
she also discovers a strategic advantage
in the midst of battle when he's knocked
into the mud bank of a river the
predator has a tough time seeing him
because being covered in cold mud has
reduced his heat signature armed with
some camouflage and makeshift traps he
engages the creature once more
through a series of clever strikes and
brute-force Dutch is able to damage the
predator who responds by taking off its
mask in an apparent show of respect for
a worthy opponent facing off on final
time at Dutch manages to capture the
creature in a trap forcing it to set up
a self-destruct bomb to eliminate any
trace of its failed hunt
the Predators return years later for
1990's predator - after witnessing the
heroism of police lieutenant Michael
Harrigan this new predator proceeds to
hunt the cops and robbers in his orbit
Harrigan and knowingly tracks the
monster before encountering agent Peter
Keyes who informs him that the US
government is aware of the
extra-terrestrial threat alien key
reveals about with Dutch and Central
America
was only the latest in a string of
encounters in combat zones after
discovering that the predator feasts on
animal meets the Fed sets up a trap for
the predator at a slaughterhouse
thinking they at the upper hand by
masking their heat signatures however
the predator switches to a different
view on his helmet and tracks their
flashlights with any advantage they
might have had now kaput everyone but
Harrigan is killed eventually Harrigan
chases a predator to a chip and engages
it in single combats after he scores an
arrow when several more predators
include themselves and collect their
dead comrades body they present her a
gun with an antique pistol as a trophy
for besting their champion and allow him
to leave the ship an harmed before they
take off in defeat this is where things
get complicated the same year fans
caught a brief glimpse of a xenomorph
skull in predator 2 Fox which owned both
the Alien and Predator movie franchises
licensed a series of crossover comic
tie-ins that eventually led to the 2004
film alien vs. predator though not well
received critically AVP provides perhaps
the biggest glimpse into the culture and
the purpose of the Predators in the film
a group of scientists led by industrial
tycoon Charles Bishop Weyland discovers
an underground pyramid some 2,000 feet
beneath the ice in Norway Weyland leads
the team on an exploratory mission just
as a trio of predators arrive at the
entrance to the pyramid through their
exploration they learn that the predator
species created the Xenomorphs from
early humans who had worshipped the
invaders as gods and allowed themselves
to be transformed into the ultimate prey
every 100 years the Predators return to
create and hunt the human sacrifices
certain xenomorph and a rites of passage
for their species
[Music]
two of the trios sent to the 2004 hunt
die quickly while one manages to
eradicate the century xenomorph threat
by befriending a tough-as-nails woman
named Alexa woods as a slew of predators
that have been surveying the conflict
appear they to offer her a weapon as a
trophy for a successful fight and to
leave that their fallen comrade
presumably back to their planet
however as soon as they leave the dead
predator alone a predator xenomorph
hybrid emerges from its chest to
terrorize a ship full of hunters before
it even leaves us atmosphere alien vs.
predator was followed by a sequel aliens
vs. predator Requiem but there's an
ongoing debate over whether these films
counts as canonical for either franchise
when Ridley Scott returned to the Alien
franchise for the prequels Prometheus
and alien covenants he completely
ignored the AVP story of the Xenomorphs
origins aliens vs. predator Requiem
picks up right after the events of AVP
with a hybrid on board that we were
referred to as the pred a lien the ship
from the end of the previous film crash
lands in Colorado a lone survivor sends
a signal to the predator homeworld
warning then that the xenomorph threat
persists one hunter takes it upon
himself to go to earth and eliminate
them and fortunately the sequel focuses
heavily on the members of the small
Colorado town by the predator and prey
alien have their conflict as a result it
doesn't do much to further the story of
the species other than to highlight the
lengths of predators we'll go to in
order to claim victory over the
Xenomorphs the movies climax sees a
predator facing off against the
predation in single combats both of them
infect mortal wounds on the other before
the government drops a tactical nuke on
the small town that's now overrun with
aliens and that's that the film ends
with the Predators plasma blaster fall
into the hands of Valens corporate
partner yutani who declares that the
world simply isn't ready for this kind
of technology to be unleashed on human
beings set days before Halloween in 2018
the predator kicks off as a group of
soldiers is attacked by one of the alien
creatures during a mission on foreign
soil US Army Ranger Quinn McKenna
manages to survive and mail himself some
of the creatures armor as proof of its
existence he's - briefed and held
captive with a ragtag group of other
soldiers when the predator in question
wakes up and it's definitely not
thrilled to find itself in a government
lab the predator quickly escapes
prompting the soldiers to steal a prison
bus and set off on a mission to retrieve
the mailed armor
when they arrived at McKenna's house
they find his son took the armor to wear
as a makeshift Halloween costume with
her predator on their tail they tracked
down the boy and retrieved the armor
eventually the predator catches up and
forces them to surrender the items only
to be killed when a larger predator
suddenly shows up this new
beastly-looking alien reveals through a
voice translator other species have
stepped up its hunting game and is now
collecting DNA of other species to
create stronger hybrids it's theorized
in the film that because predators like
a warm climate global warming is hurting
humanity toward becoming the most
attractive new hotspot for invasion it
also turns out that the original
predator that attacked McKenna and his
gang was delivering a mysterious package
to humanity and that it also carried a
shocking amount of human DNA in its own
genetic code the film ends of McKenna
and a group of scientists realized
another package the predator delivered
was left on purpose
inside is a suit designed to fit on a
human body one that looks like it's made
for the specific purpose of combating
predators it doesn't take long for
McKenna to call dibs on the new tech
meaning humanity is now prepared to
fight fire with fire the next time the
Predators come a-hunting that's my new
suit bubble 2010's predators begins when
a group of soldiers from all around the
world wake up to find themselves falling
from the sky after realizing that
they're dealing with predators a group
of strangers to doose's that they've
been hand-picked as some of Earth's
greatest warriors and brought to some
kind of intergalactic Game Preserve
where the game their theory is proven
rights when they discover a madman who
has survived in a new planet for what he
calls ten seasons by scavenging and
hiding he also reveals that there is a
blood feud between the normal-looking
creditors our fans have seen in previous
movies and new larger predators it seems
that the Predators DNA splicing
eventually went awry causing a rift
among the species while it seems that
the Predators use the game preserve to
sharpen their hunting skills it's also
possible that the technology brought to
earth in the predator made it so the
planets is no longer a viable hunting
ground which clearly hasn't stopped them
from bringing the hunt to their own turf
sadly although two members of the party
defeat the monsters they fail in their
mission to get off the planet and back
home to safety as a result no one on
earth knows about this new strategy of
kidnapping humans to hunt off planet
meaning McKenna's cornu suits may be
useless to save humanity after all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the bail so you don't miss a single one
[Music]